would you rather own a small piece of
something huge or a big piece or
everything of something much smaller
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
sam where are you dude this looks
awesome you're at like a pool or
backyard you're in the hamptons what's
going on
i spent the weekend at my in-laws house
in the hamptons and i felt pretty sick
yesterday so i just stayed the night
here i didn't feel well but i'm feeling
fine now but i'm in i'm in the hamptons
it looks good right
i mean it looks amazing yeah it looks
like what i've never been to the
hamptons
not even close
never got an invite i don't even know
anyone that lives in the hamptons let me
let me tell you away
okay my opinion of the hamptons
incredibly overrated you want to know
another thing that's incredibly
overrated central park central park so
overrated
central park and the hamptons both
overrated the hamptons not it's not that
pretty
it's not that pretty at all so very so
what's the appeal what is good about it
if you're in new york
it's only an hour hour and a half away
without traffic so you can go to the
beach there so it's a little bit like
sonoma or napa like i think those places
are nice
they're not the best they're kind of
boring as far as napa is napa and sonoma
are prettier than the hamptons without a
doubt in my opinion
oh okay interesting and uh do you
like do you feel different you walk
around every car is like a bentley or
better
you have to have a range rover to fit in
it's crazy man i it's not my style at
all it's very it's not it's not even
remotely my style um
did you see the jake fall paul and uh
tyrone tyron woodley fight last night
did i tell my wife i can't help with the
kids bedtime routine because i'm
watching the jake paul fight yeah i did
that and i watched that fight and i
thoroughly enjoyed myself it was an
amazing fight
i thought it was um a good fight i
thought jake paul i had higher
expectations the drama was there like
the most time where the technical boxing
was great i'm saying the drama was there
i didn't know what was gonna happen
beforehand and then every round it still
felt like anything could happen which is
what you want the drama was so high
my my my anxiety level was equal to the
best ufc fight like uh like the best
grudge ufc fight my like anxiety level
was equal to it i thought it was amazing
we had jake paul in the podcast he uh
was way different on the podcast than he
was in uh like for the for this whole uh
boxing thing but anyway
it was i was gonna tweet it out i was
like hey uh congrats to to guest of
episode 170 on your victory tonight
yeah it was it was a fun fight i'm happy
i got to watch it it was more it was
more intense than any you have as
intense as any ufc fight i've ever seen
it was pretty badass they've done an
amazing job well let's talk about it a
little bit uh so they for for those who
don't know or kind of just roll your
eyes
at uh you're watching jake paul and
jake paul fight this guy is this rigged
what's the point of this isn't he a
youtuber
like
i got a lot of respect for what they did
i'm pretty impressed by this i think
that
this move they did to go from
youtuber
viner to youtuber
and then youtuber to
basically one of the best business
models you can do as a
uh as a single person is basically sell
pay-per-views
and uh why is that right so like this
fight i wouldn't be surprised if they
sold a million pay-per-views
and so you sell a million pay-per-views
at you know roughly 60 bucks a
pay-per-view you know per
um you know that's 60 million dollars
and then they partner up with showtime
to do that to that whole thing and so
you know they can make 10 million bucks
in one hour doing this right in
basically a single event
and you that's totally different and and
it grows their brand like this whole
thing makes them more famous because
espn is talking about it and twitter is
talking about it everybody's talking
about it
and uh they're doing kind of like a
hobby that they like which is
boxing right they train hard so it's not
easy
but man is it lucrative so like pretty
impressive jump from one platform to the
next and as a business person i think
they're geniuses i think they are
whether it's intentional unintentional
they are geniuses uh the way that they
approach this the way that they promote
these things the way they leverage the
brand
it's genius also getting in a ring in
front of a million people getting in a
ring in front of 50 people it's
incredibly frightening now to do it with
someone who's like even though woodley's
yeah he's at the end of his career he's
40.
he [__] kills people like he crushes
people like he could he you definitely
could die i mean it's not likely but you
could and that's incredibly bold and
very likely you could get humiliated
knocked out brutally by this guy you
know in front of everybody yeah 100
and so i do think it's incredibly
courageous even though
whether i agree or don't agree with like
a lot of the [__] they do
it's wild i can't believe they've pulled
this off it's wild it's incredibly wild
the crowd on tv i've been to like three
or four or five i forget how many ufc
fights and i've been to some of the big
ones at madison square garden the crowd
on the tv like on the x in cleveland
last night yeah it felt the same as when
i saw ufc fight like the same energy it
was pretty wild they built this they
yeah they did it they pulled it off um i
also went to uh
a live mma fight a local one here in san
francisco where uh in the uh the dragon
den dragon house yeah amazing you went
to one i mean do we go together this
weekend i went to one i've been to a
bunch there it's badass right it's way
scarier than ufc it was way more intense
so we get caged side seats because
they're only 50 bucks right so like the
yeah you know it's not a huge stadium
it's keys our stadium it's a very small
place but
uh we went there we get cage site seats
for 50 bucks
since covid you know started and they
said like oh everybody's got to be
vaccinated they didn't check anything at
the door so that was not so great but i
walk in and
the crowd is just lit i don't know what
they're all they're all like super drunk
yeah so so i think there's like four or
five factors going in so first of all
it's their friends fighting usually so
like there's a whole in every fight
there's at least like 20 people that are
there because they're friends with this
person because these are amateur fights
these are people who by day you know
they deliver for doordash or they like
work in a you know consulting company or
whatever and then this is like a
nighttime fight club thing for them
where they just like decided screw it
i'm gonna try this um because i get
there early i get there for the amateur
fights before i find those way more
interesting than the pro fights and um
so first of all there's 20 people that
for that that's their friend that's
their brother that's their kid i'm
seeing moms just yelling like kill him
because it's like their son in the in
the ring or whatever
second thing is um
it's like
people are drunk yeah so people are
drinking there's only like there's a
drop in there if one consecutive it's
only beer
well they only sell they only sell beer
and costco pizza right yeah exactly
it's like beer and things that make you
want beer and then third thing is um i
think so
i think the third one would be
i'm so used to like you're in the
hamptons right now dude i
i just hang out online on tech twitter
and crypto twitter and like the group of
people i normally hang out with are so
nerdy and
like they're just concerned about
different things the priorities are
different i went to this thing and
everybody's like super dressed up like
not like fancy but they were dressed up
like i might i might meet someone here
like this is like a club to them right
um i just feel like everybody here it
was like more real people than the like
kind of
bubble that i usually live in and so it
was just different it was like shocking
there was three fights that broke out in
the crowd just after after if i would be
done i probably would break out in the
crowd and i'm sitting there with my
sister and my brother-in-law and we're
just hoping it doesn't happen near us
and the last thing was covet like
covet i think has riled people up like
when i came in i was telling my
brother-in-law i was like dude this
crowd is way better than the last time
we came to dragon house rico he goes
dude people are ready to live he's like
people were just ready to get out and
you could see it dude people were just
like
i don't know i don't know how the kids
use the word lit but people were lit at
this event this was the whole event was
lit it was i love going to those i've
probably been to three of them were the
mongols there i guess they weren't there
because uh they can't travel
no
i've been there and there's they have
there's like a large like contingency
and mongolians and and they have their
family there was one mongolian fighter
and he yeah his crowd was like his crew
was pretty crazy and then
he fought this irish dude and i swear to
god it was like conor mcgregor came out
as soon as the guy comes out it's like
the whole crowd is chanting olay i'm
like where did this huge irish
contingent come from he's got a tattoo
silhouette of ireland on the side of his
body he gets in the ring and they had a
crazy fight and so it was it was a lot
of fun first of all so if you have like
a
i don't know if people i don't know if
it's only people who like ufc but if you
like ufc which is like maybe one percent
of our audience
go to a local show
i bet it's more
go to a local show i i didn't think it
would be this good it's like amazing it
was like truly amazing but it also made
me feel like
what is it about people who why would
anybody sign up to do this and then i
know you are the type who you signed up
to get punched in the face quite a bit
what's the appeal and would you ever do
this
well i signed up for a smoker so what a
smoker is is
it's uh amateurs so there's no judges
and typically you can kind of have like
in a like you can like say ahead of time
like hey i'm new you're new like you're
you don't actually at the fight that you
went into they're going in with bad
intentions you know they want to hurt
you with the thing that i signed up for
sometimes like you'd be like hey let's
let's get after it and you'll try to
knock people out and you might get
knocked out but it's like not nearly as
angry and you could like say hey we're
going too hard let's take it easy so
it's like a sparring session
it's above a sparring session but it's
not quite a real fight or at least it
doesn't have to be and i signed up for
it because
it makes me feel alive it makes me feel
uh like i feel soft when i just sit in
front of the computer all day it makes
me feel good to survive getting beat up
because i know that i'm not going to be
stressed out about anything else that
i'm going to do throughout the day
because like when i stress out about
like this podcast or if i get mad that
our freaking internet wasn't working
really well i'm like dawg i just got my
ass kicked like like this like
everything else is fine
exactly i went skydiving once and we did
it in the morning it was like eight in
the morning and so the rest of the day
like you know from 8 30 onward because
i'd have to only last like five minutes
like you're just you fall for 60 seconds
and then you kind of float down gently
for five minutes and then it's over but
the rest of that day i was like i
couldn't be bothered by anything i was
like dude i jumped out of a plane this
morning you think i'm gonna worry about
this presentation i have or this person
who didn't call me back or this person
who cut me in line like bro i flew i was
flying in the air this morning and so it
was like if i could bottle that feeling
up and have it more often which it
sounds like you get by by sparring what
not that's pretty good i also have been
re-watching breaking bad so did you
watch breaking bad like once
yeah so i just i just started
re-watching it
and uh it's like enough years have gone
by where i kind of forgot it
and that's basically the premise of the
show the show is basically this guy
lived kind of his whole life you know by
the book and was like always like kind
of just like worried about you know he
didn't want to offend anybody he didn't
take much risk blah blah blah and then
when he finds out that he's got you know
a few months to live he starts doing
this stuff
initially to help his family like how do
i how do i provide for my family if i
pass away i don't want them to have
nothing because i'm just a teacher i
didn't save up too much money
and then once he starts to do it it
starts to feel good he starts to feel
alive and so this has become kind of
like a theme i'm thinking about and like
if we want to tie this to business i'll
force it here which is
there's probably a whole set of products
or experiences
that just make somebody feel alive and
they're kind of counterintuitive like
why would you choose to get punched in
the face why would you choose to take
this risk and almost get caught by the
cops
and then how do you bottle that up and
package that in a product or service so
that because i think a lot of people do
want this feeling and once they get it i
think it's very addictive
but i would say that that's what you do
with a lot of your investments right
like when i think about what you're
doing with an nft or what you're doing
with crypto to me it's a high adrenaline
high risk uh
type of thing right
uh kind of i think you'd think i take
more risk than i actually do but uh but
yeah i could see that that's definitely
a piece of it there's a bit of the
roller coaster that you get to go on and
the roller coasters for a thrill seeker
but i just think in general like
you know we were in la i went to
disneyland why are there even roller
coasters right well because people
in 30 seconds you can get that feeling
like you might die and then you live and
that little package
that thrills it taps into this real
secret part of people and i just feel
like there's probably more experiences
that could be built that are like that i
think if you're building in vr for
example
instead of trying to build a vr like
kind of like fantasy land i would build
things in vr that make people feel
a little bit afraid a little bit scared
a little bit alive i think a lot of
video games try this right like it's why
a lot of video games are out shooting
people and stuff like that because it's
it's cool and it's an escape and
something you can't do in real life so
you get to live vicariously through this
but i just think there's a lot more that
could be done
so instead of talking about
fear can i tell you something that i
read recently that's it's about
happiness can i tell you something that
totally kind of like i read something
recently and the data seems pretty clear
and it totally like goes against what
we've been told previously can i tell
you about that so layout layout what
we've been told and then what you saw so
the you know there's these like things
that you see headlines so one of these
headlines is like the average american
doesn't have 500 in savings or something
like that that's that's that's mostly
[__] by the way that's a [__]
headline but the other one was that
after you make 75 000
your perceived happiness level doesn't
really go up significantly
and i read about that a while ago we
read about i mean when did that come out
you think like in 2012 or something
2013. yeah i feel like i've heard this
kind of my whole professional life so
maybe at least 12 15 years something
like that i've always thought that that
was [__] i've always thought that
was [__] um
i didn't pass the sniff test for you not
even a little bit not even a little bit
and so i came across this study and so
what these guys did was they got 40 000
people to install this app and this app
at random times would ask you like they
would ask you a bunch of questions but
it would be on a scale of like one to
five or one to ten i see you're
highlighting the app you can click it
and you can see it it's called track
your happiness
yeah and it's pretty cool it's just a
simple app and what they did was they
got 35 40 000 people they ranged they
had all types of ranges and they asked
people how they felt during different
periods of the week of the day and they
would track your income
and what they found is is that while
it is true that after you get past a
certain point your happiness levels
doesn't necessarily go up in proportion
but what this study found is like up
until like 500 600 700 000 a year it was
definitely still going going up
like yeah we can we can show this graph
if you're watching on youtube we'll put
this graph on the screen and it's
basically two lines it's your life
satisfaction and your uh experience
well-being
and uh they're both
like from fifteen thousand dollars of
household income up to five hundred
thousand dollars they're tracking like
up into the right just like a straight
line so the more income you were getting
the more sort of life satisfaction you
were having
um during at each step of those it
didn't just plateau at 75 000 like the
the old kind of like that quoted quoted
study is and it may like the difference
between 2 million and 3 million probably
won't be significant but like according
to this study like the difference
between 10 million and 1 million is
significant and does impact your
happiness and that totally like kind of
broke my frame even though i always
thought it would be true i thought this
study was actually really interesting
and there's a few reason why a few
reasons why basically the other one was
nonsense was the first one was
remembered feelings so the 75 000 study
basically what they did was they asked
people how they felt in the past and
that's kind of [__] because you
always think that you remember uh things
better than you actually did or like
during during one period you'll think
it's great and then you'll say how you
remembered it and you'll think it or
sorry you'll during the time you think
it's horrible then you'll look back and
be like oh that was actually awesome
right this actually asked you right then
and there how you felt the second thing
was before it said were you happier then
or were you happier now and that's kind
of nonsense because there's no variance
like the variance is too low and like
you know sometimes like it could be well
i'm a little bit better and that matters
and so that's binary it's it's just yes
or no there's no like there's no
granularity
yeah so i don't know i thought this was
interesting i wanted to bring this up
because that's one of the it's one of
those studies that i always thought that
people base like you read this headline
and you believe this to be true and a
lot of people probably make decisions
based off of this and i think it's
important to say no that's i think it's
[__] and and you shouldn't base your
life on that data or that study
right yeah yeah and i i like uh i love
this topic by the way i think it's great
it's sort of like myth-busting of these
like common things you hear like another
one is like the ten thousand hour rule
that got really popular because malcolm
gladwell wrote this book called outliers
and he's like oh you know to be great at
something you got to spend ten thousand
hours
and uh and so then a lot of people run
with that and it's like well
there's obviously a bunch of caveats but
like the caveats get stripped away as
the thing just gets kind of like turned
into a fortune cookie tweet right it's
like ten thousand hours that's the rule
and um
and sure there's instances where
somebody spends ten thousand hours it
gets really great at something but
there's definitely instances where it
doesn't take ten thousand hours to get
graded something i've had many of them
in my life and uh and so you wanna like
i guess question a lot of these things
that you're told and try to figure out
what what's the truth and what's the
truth for me what am i going to
experience what do i choose to believe
and so i'm with you on uh on looking
into stuff like this i also think this
app is cool this tracker happiness app
i'm gonna actually use it
at my previous company
when i was running the idea lab i was my
first time uh like as ceo of like a
larger group we had like 20 something
employees
uh at that time and that was i was 25
years old it was the most people i had
ever managed
and i was like okay well how do i manage
people i was like well there's a whole
bunch of books on this but
i created something pretty simple i
asked one of the programmers i went to
this guy quinn and he's like this young
hacker guy and i was basically like hey
quinn
i would love to know i would love to
just kind of like if i could go have a
conversation with each person each day
saying hey how are you feeling uh how's
it going
i think i could be a better manager but
that would take way too much time and it
would just also be like a full-on
conversation with each person i said can
you just set up a thing so that
at the end of every
like work day so at like 4 30 p.m or
whatever
it just pings everybody individually in
slack and it just says hey sean uh how
are you feeling today you know one to
ten
and uh what's your happiness right now
and it would just i would basically do
what this app does and they would put it
in and then i had a dashboard as the
manager is the ceo that would show me
all these different people and what i
found was two things the first is
some people
have a very narrow range of emotions
that they feel so like there's like our
cto is this uh british guy paul he's a
he's very kind of like stoic he's sort
of like you know like british sort of
dry humor and so like he never got too
too high up too high down like he was
always like a you know like a seven or
an eight he didn't he never hit a ten he
never hit a five he always stayed in
that range so i had to interpret his
data differently because i was like for
this guy his self-assessment of his own
like kind of like happiness or
well-being his his range is different so
i can't just say oh eight you're good
eight is actually
great for him and a seven is actually
quite bad for him whereas for other
people who are like you know the hot
mess
folks it's like some days it's a one and
some days it's a ten
and i had to interpret them differently
so that was the first observation
the second was
when i would go and uh i could i could
ping them afterwards i could just say
you know it could basically ping them
once they submit their score it would
say cool do you want to add a note on
why
and the reasons that affected people's
happiness were so different than what i
would have expected i thought people
would be unhappy because
you know they feel like underpaid or
overworked or
you know maybe their colleagues said
something to them it was always like the
smallest [__] it's like like what
it'd be like you know it'd be something
like
oh you know
uh at lunch today uh you know i whatever
you know this table was full so i kind
of had to go sit over there or be like
you know at uh you know we're working on
this project i really wanted to get more
done but i got a phone call i got
distracted it's like they were like some
people were like really some people got
off on high output and so their
happiness was like it's like oh yeah we
had to do that team meeting and so i
didn't get to go work on my pride i
didn't get to write enough code today or
it would be like something really really
small it's like yeah i'm really dealing
with this kind of like back pain so this
chair is really uncomfortable it was
always things that i wouldn't have
otherwise seen and so it brought those
to the surface and then i could decide
is this something i could affect and
like improve or do i just like at least
i get a better understanding of them so
that was like one of the better products
that we built we probably should have
productized it and made it an actual
like work tool for other people to use
yeah i used to use this thing called
15.5 you remember that company
they're doing pretty well dude i think
they're they're pretty successful i bet
i would bet they are so they kind of
like went quiet for a little while and
typically that means it's failing
horribly or it's actually quite large
like it's usually like one of the other
uh and so it was called 15 5 and
basically they would send you fi the
whole product it was very simple and
it's probably thrived during covid but
basically they send you an email every
day and it takes
is it 15 questions that are five minutes
to answer or it's 15 minutes to answer
five questions one of those and that's
all it is is they just send you an email
at the end of the day and they say what
did you get done today how do you feel
yep
and that's all the product is and i
would imagine that it's quite large yeah
yeah i think it raised that like 130
million valuation recently or something
so you know
maybe that's a little out of date that's
2019. so i bet it's doing doing pretty
well uh all right let's do a different
topic what do you want to talk about let
me tell you about a different uh a
different company that i recently
discovered so it's called e-s-r-i
have you ever heard of that
no sounds like a government agency
kinda okay so esri so basically there's
this entire uh sector this entire
industry that needs important map
information if you scroll all the way
down to where it says felt you'll see
where i am yeah but basically the idea
here is
um there's this company called esri it
was started in the 1960s it's 100 owned
by this one guy and his brother so 100
owned by the same family no debt they've
never taken any outside funding you
can't find anything about it it does
over a billion dollars a year in
subscription revenue and basically what
it does and subscription revenue nice
yes um it's software it's assault i
guess i guess you could call it
information but probably at this point
software because it started in the 60s
so at the time it was basically
information but what it what it does is
very simple so 20 000 plus cities use it
so most cities most like reasonably
sized cities in america use it most
states use it most fortune 500 companies
use it and what it does is they have
loads of um
of information on maps and so if you're
a government and you want to build new
gas new new pipes or something like that
in your city you're going to take their
data and you can also give them more
data and that's going to give you an
interactive map that you can use to
figure out where the other pipes are and
you're going to be able to build this
this this pretty complex system that you
can continually use year over year
that's going to show where your pipes
are it's called geographic information
system you never heard you never heard
of that gis yeah i've heard that yeah i
thought for sure you would have heard of
that so um it's almost like uh google
maps on steroids so in the same way that
apple or sorry the same way it's like
b2b google maps yes in the same way uber
uses one of the apple or either uh
google maps this is what like the city
of like the hamptons would use when
they're building new roads and when
they're building new electricities now
there's a few reasons why this is
interesting one it's one of the most
complex and one of the most interesting
family-owned businesses i've ever seen
total monopoly so in the way that they
got their monopoly is they go into
colleges and so they work with
engineering students they've worked
really hard on making sure all the
colleges they give their software to for
free so the engineering students start
using it at a very young age and they're
used to it then when they graduate they
go oh yeah let's just use esri so they
know exactly what they're doing and it
has a total moat also because selling to
a government is impossibly hard it's
incredibly difficult why because when
you're a government you want to make
sure that the vendor that you're using
takes 100 responsibility if something
f's up and so when you're like signing
up if you're a government employee if
you're working on a fortune 4 500
employee you want cover your ass
insurance you know you want a company
that's like well known and like not new
and like they're going to take
responsibility if something bad happens
that's esri crazy fascinating company
but i'm curious about which businesses
are gonna because whenever you see
something old you know from the 1960s as
a software company you think
well like surely they're like you know
you can't crush it forever also the
founder of this company esri he's
probably worth 10 billion dollars at
this point i think he's like 85 years
old so he's gonna die he's gonna they're
gonna lose its way like this is just
inevitably how it works this guy's name
by the way jack dangermond
is that his name right this dangermond i
mean come on that's uh how old is this i
can see why people don't want to compete
with this guy
he's pretty old i don't know he doesn't
look like he's 80 it looks like he's you
know well he's rich
60 70 something like that uh yeah
personal fortune 4 billion dollars
himself
yeah and he started with his brother
when he was like 27. crazy fascinated
business crazy fascinating business and
never taken a cent outside of a 5 000
initial loan from dangermon's mother
crazy right crazy fascinating company
and and he seems for i mean you know
what i read about he seems like a good
guy him and his wife he's so he's an
environmentalist so he started this
because he cared about like uh wildfires
and things like that he was building
software to help create maps that um
somehow reduce wildfire which i'm gonna
explain in a second but basically
there's a new company there's a bunch of
new companies coming out the first one
is called felt so go to felt.com it
totally does not went to this it looked
it look it looked well this is like an
early access site but
my
i saw and i said oh this is kind of
interesting so i started looking into it
i read your notes on it this felt thing
seems pretty cool are you investing in
this it seems like awesome
nope i i we just i've i've never talked
to this person so it started by a guy
named sam hashimi he's his first company
was called remix it was a city
transportation planning startup that he
sold for a hundred million dollars and
he was doing that he learned all about
the uh
inadequacies of like basically using
maps and creating maps for your service
and he said well i'm gonna credit create
a better map business uh something that
uh um people can uh add stuff to and
it's almost like uh where where esri is
like google maps this is like waze so
people can contribute to it if you use
it uh kind of fascinating and um it
seems very very interesting and i always
like these old-school companies i mean i
like this company this guy jack started
i think it's badass i love seeing the
new guys that are going to try and take
this and kick their ass i think it's
very fascinating
yeah this is cool i like this a lot
there was a company called um
what's the name they're based in
they spun out of like this lab hold on i
think you actually might have their name
here
and while you're looking for that so
felt they describe it as the world's
first collaborative mapping tool and it
serves a wide range of use cases so i
imagine they haven't said this but i
imagine actually anyone can use it a
user can use it so if you're going
hiking with your friends if you're
planning a trip you're allowed to use
this i imagine what they're doing is
their grand scheme though their niche
their wedge is to help wildfires uh uh
go down and so the way that you could do
that is you can actually use data and
you can figure out where wildfires are
where they're gonna happen and then
cities will pay money to use your
mapping data in order to reduce
wildfires and i imagine what they're
going to do is they're going to create
this really cool because if you go to
felt.com it looks very um
user-focused whereas it it's they're
going to make all their money from b to
b so it doesn't look the same it doesn't
look like a b2b product i imagine what
they're going to do is like just like
waze they're going to let the consumers
use it and map out really interesting
[__] and then they're going to go and
sell the data and mapping tools to b2b
to businesses and that's how they're
going to win crazy fascinating go ahead
yeah i think it's cool so the company i
think is called discard his
and uh what this i meant the founder of
this at a dinner and he was telling me
about it and i was like wow this is kind
of amazing and this became one of my one
of my misses i was like oh i really
should invest in this and at the time i
wasn't really investing super actively
and i missed the boat i think this has
become like a very big company but at
the time i was like pretty convinced
that this is going to be a winner
and why is that so they spun out of los
alamos
alamos national labs or whatever which
is like in new mexico or albuquerque or
something like that it's like this like
it's kind of like you know nasa or
something like that so this is like
highly kind of scientific community they
spin out they create this commercial
company um that's called discard this
labs and what they do is they do
satellite imagery so they would
basically take i don't know if it was
their own satellites or other people's
satellites but they would take the
imagery of like cool there's this image
from a satellite of a field
and then they could run all kinds of
machine learning and like kind of
computer vision and different like tech
more modern technologies on top of that
and they could give a hedge fund an idea
of how much corn yield there is this
year or they could give you know so it's
like if you ever watch billions they
kind of do something sometimes where
it's like oh look how many trucks are
leaving this factory so before the
earnings call i can figure out you know
how much volume they're doing because i
can see the rate of change from before
to after things like that so so they
have a whole bunch of different products
but basically at the time it was like
they were like trying to figure out how
to use it i think he told me the story
and this is many years ago so i may be
getting this wrong but i think what he
told me was
at the time they didn't have that many
customers but their business model was
basically just betting on like
futures of corn crop yields or something
like that because they're like they're
putting their own they were their own
balance sheet they were just betting
basically and they were showing that
like look we can actually generate
returns using this strategy because
that's how valuable our data is and i
think since then i think that was early
on when they were like just making the
technology and playing with it but um
either was them or they've been a
partner doing that and now i think they
have a lot more customers who are
looking for this whether it's like
you know a agriculture company that has
some need because they need to predict
you know the way that the world is
changing the way that the the the way
that um anything any data that you can
get from satellite imagery is basically
what they do so i really like that
business model as well some people are
doing that in terms of getting
satellites into space and other people
are doing it taking the satellite
imagery and making more sense of it
making more getting more actionable like
data and insights from that
did you say the name of the company in
front of the founder
the name of what
company oh no no he told me am i saying
it wrong
is it french
have you heard of the philosopher
descartes
yeah what's the french philosopher's
name renee descar
maybe maybe that's what it is what did
you call it
descartes
it's descartes yeah it's the car it's
like it's like the i don't i forget uh
renee descartes is he the guy who said i
think therefore i am uh anyway it's
that's well i think therefore uh i know
i know that i got that pretty bad pretty
badly wrong i i met this guy years ago
so i don't even fully remember the idea
i just remember thinking oh that's
interesting all my friends are making
like apps to like order pizza and like
to-do lists and stuff like that and this
guy's basically taking satellite imagery
and looking at it and it
my two takeaways were i should probably
invest in this guy and the second thing
was why am i not doing something more
interesting with my life
because that sounds way more cool and
interesting and like
probably valuable than competing in this
competing around ideas that everybody
has and that everybody could kind of do
and so that was a you know a takeaway i
had during that process
um you want me to keep going or you want
one no do one
all right let me tell you a quick story
about a guy named wayne hazinga
i love wayne hezinga i read his book i
believe it's called uh building
blockbuster so there's this guy named
wayne huzzingo where all right now i'm
gonna sound uncultured is he from i
always get it confused
holland in the netherlands and dutch
are they all the same thing
dutch is a way to describe people i
think from the netherlands i think
holland might be a part of the
netherlands i'm not sure dude i don't
know i'm sounding on culture i'm sorry
but what what does it say what does
wayne huzinga say so he's of dutch
descent
dutch descent came to united states from
the netherlands all right good all right
so he's born in 1937 all right so listen
to the story of this guy born in 1937
parents divorced at a young age went to
the army and when he was in his 20s he
started this company called waste
management basically he had one moving
truck
or one truck and he started a waste
management business where he would just
go from door to door throwing away your
trash
and eventually like after only a short
amount of time like two years he starts
realizing that these uh this this
business is incredibly um there's a
there's loads of small players who all
just own little bits and pieces and he
goes well [__] i'm just gonna buy all of
them and so he starts buying a [__] ton
of them something like two or three a
week um and is a business eventually
because has become waste management
today it's got a 64 billion dollar
market cap it's uh the biggest waste
removal company in the country and it's
incredibly big and he left that in 1984
so he built this huge business and you
think all right so uh that's great go
and chill
next when he was still in his 50s i
believe he starts a company called
blockbuster and so this is in 1987.
he uh bought he found one blockbuster it
was one blockbuster store he bought it
uh with a little bit of money and he
took it public like two years later so
this guy's like a financial arbitrage
machine so he's like is really good at
raising money and deploying capital and
so he raises this money and so
blockbuster after like two years it has
seven million dollars in revenue 19
stores and then in just a handful of
years he gives it to 4 billion in
revenue in 3 000 stores in 11 countries
and eventually he sells it to vicom in
1994 this is about uh eight years after
starting the company for eight and a
half billion dollars and so it's pretty
crazy and if you would have invested 25
000 and so he would let some friends
invest and if you would have invested 25
000 in into a blockbuster when it went
public in
in 1987 it would have been worth about a
million dollars when they sold so he's
pretty amazing i mean he's he's got a
good track record so he also started
something else right he'll started yeah
yeah so the guy all right so he's in
waste management he's in blockbuster at
this point he's in the 60s you think all
right now you're just gonna chill
absolutely not he starts autonation
which is at this point it's the largest
seller of used cars in america so he
went from waste management to
blockbuster to cars and then throughout
this whole period he's also doing the
same with resort so have you ever heard
of uh extended stay america i believe
now it's owned by marriott you never
heard of extended save america so
basically they've got they've got
something like five six seven hundred uh
motels that are nice enough that you
could stay for like
a handful or like a month or like two
four weeks at a time he started that he
also started a bunch of different golf
clubs and then in the 90s he eventually
buys the miami dolphins and i think he
bought another florida uh what's the
florida football team well so that's the
dolphins and then he buy the the florida
marlins also the baseball team the
marlins uh pretty amazing is this and
and and so i always was amazed at this
guy and um the reason i was amazed at
him is he had an incredibly positive
attitude when he was doing this whole
thing and so here's a few things here's
a few quotes that i have from his
biography that he talked about were his
philosophy the first we made small
acquisitions in different states around
the united states it was just easier
faster and cheaper to go in and buy a
guy who was already established in a
market even if it was very small then
i'd hire a bunch of sales people to go
out and do the internal growth the plan
was always to have internal growth but
in order to get internal growth growing
quickly would sometimes either go out at
a certain market and just buy uh
buy a guy who had three or four trucks
and say okay let's do this on our own
and that's what he did over and over and
over and over again and he did it in all
those businesses except for blockbuster
but even then he did it with blockbuster
because he started the brand but and
they grew on their own but eventually
they started buying like loads of
different mom-and-pop mom-and-pop movie
stores and this was his whole strategy
there's another guy who did this his
name is bradley jacobs he's uh is worth
like five or ten billion dollars he did
this over and over and over again and i
think that there's still a ton of room
to do this so
what what other industries could you do
this in i've been thinking about this a
lot and i'm not entirely educated on the
topic but i think
i think you could do it for all types of
moving businesses because moving
businesses there's not actually one
leader that you trust who's like the
best right it's like a lot of mom and
pop stores um what other industries
could you do this like consolidation
stuff in
i mean these roll-ups happen kind of in
every industry i feel like people have
done it with dentists
right now dentist is like the hottest
thing going there's also like pet you
know uh vets you know veterinary
hospitals or veterinary clinics there's
pet cemeteries that somebody has told us
about that that's like a
pet cremation basically is like another
one that you could do again fragmented
market there's there's a lot of these
there's rural wireless internet service
providers there's
there's a
huge number of these where in a local
market there's somebody who has maybe
not a local monopoly but a large local
footprint
and uh
and going in you can't it's very it
would be it would be too expensive to go
in and try to rebuild that it would take
too long and be too hard to do that in a
small place so you buy it at a fair
price but you buy a whole lot of these
and you make the the sort of the sum
greater than than than
than the parts and so i think this
roll-up strategy
is
one of the more like i would say
intriguing ways to build a monstrous
empire like otherwise you kind of got to
build a you know build a facebook build
a youtube it it's very hard to build a
multi-billion dollar individual company
from scratch i think it is far easier to
execute one of these roll-ups and create
you know 100 million dollars create even
a billion dollars of value in you know
five to ten years
it doesn't interest me personally but if
i wanted to become a billionaire i think
that this would be one of the lower risk
ways to get it done um
one redux did this with local newspapers
also so rupert murdoch this is kind of
what he did local newspapers and then
local radio stations local television
stations whatever he basically bought
local media companies and then
aggregated them and rolled them all up
and created like giant basically news
corp which is his his like mothership
brand um so yeah by the way this guy
wayne hazinga if you're watching on
youtube put this guy's face on here from
his wikipedia
looks like an evil steve ballmer so that
that's what this guy looks like bradley
jacobs the other guy you mentioned who's
done this with xpeo logistics and a
couple other companies
literally looks like couldn't be a
sweeter you know someone sweet
sweetheart dad who uh you know coaches
the local soccer team uh i i love
looking at these because i think to do
this you got to be pretty i don't want
to say ruthless but extremely aggressive
ambitious a great deal maker and um and
and you're moving like at a freight
train's pace and so i love to meet these
people now you can't meet them sometimes
i love to just even look at their photos
and just just read their bios who's this
person where did they come from because
it takes a very specific attitude to be
able to go do this with self storage or
local you know landscapers pool
construction companies rolling them all
up i've read a lot about uh both of
those guys and i've seen them talk
on youtube and my opinion of them is
that they seem highly ethical they seem
incredibly high energy super high energy
and they seem very entrepreneurial even
though they both look like wall street
suits that don't like create these guys
definitely are creators even though they
buy stuff and you think well that's not
like you're not inventing anything and
maybe they're not inventing anything
from scratch but they're definitely
creators um and i because i remember i
saw that guy bradley jacobs and i saw
what he looked like and i'm like dude
this [__] suit like he's just like
he's just some arbitrage square and he's
not he totally uh he's a he's a creator
and it's really interesting he's maybe
not like mark zuckerberg where he's like
coding [__] but he's a different type of
creator and i really like these types of
folks
doesn't this seem a little low this
guy's net worth was 2.8 billion when he
died i feel like how is this guy's net
worth so low compared to
doing autonation waste management system
doing uh doing a blockbuster like how is
that how does that add up i think that
the number that we have there could be
wrong but i think it's wrong what i read
about in his biography was that with uh
with waste management because they
raised so much money and because they
bought so many companies they simply
didn't own that much of it i mean they
owned a smaller piece of a massive pie
and they were okay doing that and so
when he started waste management and
when he left uh
he was the largest individual
shareholder i believe but he probably
owned like single digit percentage right
yeah even just owning the dolphins i
feel like the dolphins themselves are
going to be you know 500 million to a
billion dollar franchise so that seems a
little a little low but yeah this guy's
definitely the billy of the week uh
extremely
impressive career uh you know shout out
to uh to this guy he looks like he
passed away yeah a couple of years ago
at age 80. um so you know respect okay
what else we want to talk about i have a
i have another kind of fast growing
company i think it's worth talking about
this thing called picasso have you seen
this no i'm gonna google it is that how
it's spelled
picasso yeah p-a-c-a-s-o
so
two execs at zillow
spun out and created this thing i think
a year ago
and it's already worth one or two
billion dollars kind of in startup
valuation world so i think they created
all that value in basically a year and a
year and a half
and um and what does it do it's
basically a [__] time share so what
they do is they buy homes
they convert them to a llc
and then they sell fractions of that
home
um to investors so they bought like you
know let's say a house in napa valley
they go buy a million dollar house they
convert it into uh
slices of one-eighth so you can own an
eighth of this house for whatever 125
thousand dollars you can buy a piece of
this home
so you're a fractional homeowner
and it's meant to be for second homes so
you don't do this for your home you do
this for your like second your vacation
home and uh when you buy that one-eighth
of the house that gets you 44 nights of
a stay
in that home for the year and you can
either use them yourself you can gift
them to others i think you can rent them
out or get let them rent it out for you
and this company takes
this insane rake so they take 12 of the
purchase price uh up front just straight
off the bat and then they charge you a
monthly management fee because they have
the app that you and the other owners
use to coordinate who's booking what
what's the what's the rental share what
are you how are you sharing expenses all
that good stuff and if you know if the
house goes down
you you know you're on the hook for it
they took their money up front so i
thought this was kind of a
incredible riff on a time share
that uh i'm surprised frankly i'm
surprised is growing this fast i didn't
like it doesn't it's not something i
look at and i say that's awesome i wish
i had done that or thought of that idea
i actually think this is kind of
dumb what do you think so time shares i
mean timeshare is a huge business i i
like the idea of a time share is not bad
i would i would be into owning one it's
just that i don't want to go like
through the sleaziness of of
of
you know what i mean like you want to
sit through the webinar yeah i don't
want to i don't want to go to the
seminar so it's weird so i think it
could be cool why is it worth so much so
fast
uh yeah i don't know i don't know i mean
they've grown you know so it's picasso
evaluation
i saw it because there was a big protest
going on so picasso raises 75 million
goes from launch to unicorn in five
months
so i think part of it is what was the
protest
what's that you said there's a protest
oh the protest was basically like in
napa the home that they bought the
neighborhood was like yo what is this uh
like we don't want uh
we don't want this we don't want this
like timeshare rental we don't want all
these different people coming through
why why are they doing this and so um so
they basically
you know they were they're trying to
like they were trying to say hey time
shares are not allowed and what this
company says is it's not a time share in
a time sure you own
a block of time in this you actually are
a part owner of the home so it's
different than a time share and then
people were like dude you can't just
call it cooperative ownership make up a
new term and like it's a time share and
so they're kind of going back and forth
uh about that so the guy who started his
name is spencel spencer raskoff is that
how to say his name so he started
and austin allison so she's actually the
ceo they were both execs at solo so yeah
so one of the co-founders name is
spencer have you seen what this guy's
done before
no the name sounds familiar wasn't he
one of the original like founders of
zillow like yeah so check this out in 99
at the age of 24 he founded hotwire.com
a leading travel internet company i mean
obviously that's hotels right they sold
it for 700 million dollars then he
started zillow and he took it public he
was a ceo through its ipo and
bought loads of different companies uh
he's resigned in 2020 so i guess he's
out entirely uh
then he started la which is a media
company for
a california startup so i guess that's
kind of like a passion project and then
now he's started picasso dude this guy's
prolific and he's on the board of
pallets here this guy this is why it's
worth a billion dollars because it's
like oh the ex-ceo of zillow is doing
this new real estate thing cool we're
we're in and we're sort of price
insensitive on the valuation so i think
it has more to do with the team than it
does probably the traction in terms of
that valuation yeah this guy's a badass
i mean he's he's a hardcore badass would
you would you want
when i think of these types of things
these companies that raise all this
money we talked about zillow or we
talked about this company picasso and
the this guy looks like spencer that's
his history also a podcaster
he's got office hours podcast there you
go oh we should have him on here spencer
if you're listening come on do you think
that do you like this strategy of
raising would you rather own a small
piece of something huge or a big piece
or everything of something much smaller
um i don't think about it that like that
wouldn't be the deciding criteria if it
was just between those two i would
rather own the whole thing of a smaller
of a smaller thing i find it to be
more fulfilling and i think economically
you end up doing better you have more
options because when you own a small
piece
of a bigger thing
if it happens to go a little sideways
and doesn't have big unicorn exit
doesn't go public doesn't get
sold for three billion dollars
it's very easy to kind of walk away with
very little because you raised all this
money so now you have the first 100
million dollars go back to investors and
maybe you only sold it for for 70 or
something like that whereas
you owned like a huge amount of the
hustle i think that path is better
because you could sell for 12 million
dollars and walk away with 10 million
dollars you know like out of it and so
and so i think it's a
it gives you more options on how to
build your wealth now that being said
there's something fun about building
something massive and going for
something that's like
truly game changing with three extra
zeros on the back of it so like you know
i respect both pat's if i was picking
between those two i would own i would
want to own more of a smaller thing
because it gives me more options what do
you think is easier
oh for sure owning uh
owning a small thing now easier in one
sense which is
it is easier i think on a day-to-day
basis because you don't have to worry
about fundraising shareholders other
shareholder management and you can again
you can exit for smaller amounts the
harder part when you go rate like these
guys just raise 75 million dollars
they're not gonna feel like they're like
roughing it
every day whereas when it's your company
and like i don't know you probably ran
payroll for you know in the first year
of the hustle
and um and you probably had to worry
like let's say you know advertisers pull
out
you know you probably were feeling that
pinch because you were
more or less bootstrapped you raised a
little bit of money but like right i
don't think you ever felt like
you know you have this huge cash cushion
that you can just fall back on
well yeah i did not but my opinion i i
normally would have agreed with you but
we had mark laurie on the podcast and i
talked oh i had a lot of his co-workers
reach out to me after the podcast and
basically mark laurie is our judge.com
and what he's done is he uh he what was
his vision he had his like he had this
like phrase and i forget the phrase but
it was like a vision capital people is
that what it was yeah
that's his uh his his fun name now so we
could look it up uh but yeah it's it's
vision capital people yeah you gotta
write vcp vision and so he like that was
his whole premise he's like everything i
come up with the vision i get the
capital we get the people that's what we
do and when he says that i'm like
that like what does that mean like
that's a pretty like a vague fluffy
thing but i started talking to people
who worked with them and they're like
he did that so well where he would raise
all this money and he really like he did
a lot of work but it wasn't like he
he wasn't like doing like like like like
you know the [__] that you do when
you're just starting out when you don't
have any money you know uh uh like i i
ran my own payroll i did all the banking
i did you know i would go out and get
all the vendors he was like he just like
hired amazing people and they did most
of the work and he just took care of the
hard part of like selling people to uh
join the company and selling people to
give them money and i thought about that
i'm like dude that does sound so easy
yeah it's not crazy it's not that it's
easy it's awesome i thought i'd put it
nothing's easy anything anything
valuable is typically
you don't go to it because it's easy
necessarily but um
i i'm totally with you i
what's what's more fun a small vision or
a big vision a big vision right
what's uh what feels better having a lot
of ammo you know in terms of capital or
being strapped for cash and always work
not only having to worry about how to
get customers and grow but can we pay
the bills every single month yeah
definitely
on the other side
if sean wants to [__] off for a little
while you can do that yeah you know you
could you could you can bail for a
little i optimize for freedom i optimize
for freedom above above most things and
so like if you ask me would i rather my
my dad taught me this a long time ago he
told me once because or my first startup
was a sushi restaurant chain
and
i was like i was talking about you know
why it's fun blah blah blah he goes
he was trying to convince me to come
work in the energy industry he's like he
he worked at bp so he worked in the oil
and gas industry and he's like he's like
you know the minimum it's like you like
to play poker right now when you go to a
poker table you can either sit down with
a hundred dollars or you can sit down
with ten thousand dollars or a hundred
thousand dollars you're still playing
the same game you're still gonna sit
there for six hours he's like it's why
not play the bigger game and he's like
in the energy industry the minimum
stakes are in the millions nothing
happens in the hundreds of thousands of
dollars like you're saying a restaurant
one location if it works can produce a
hundred thousand dollars a year of net
income or 125 thousand dollars in net
income he's like why not just he's like
a small project and a big project if you
make it your your obsession which is
what you're going to do when you go
start a startup
they both take the same amount of time
they're both going to be all consuming
all right so might as well do the one
that has the bigger payoff so when he
said it like that i was pretty sure like
that's why my next start i stopped the
food thing and i went and did a biotech
company because he was right and biotech
like
our we made one deal it was worth five
million dollars and i was like wow that
would have taken us like five years and
25 locations to do in the restaurant
industry and this was like one one great
meeting one great presentation and like
you know a year of technology
development and boom five million
dollars came through the door so i kind
of got to taste both sides of it and so
if i was gonna
a big project and a small project both
take the same time a big project's more
fun
but what i don't like is big companies
because in big companies i feel like i
lose my freedom of my time my energy of
how i want to spend my day and so that's
why i'm trying to find this mix of
my perfect situation is i work for
myself and pretty much by myself
but i'm working on things that i feel
are big and can pay off big and with the
world of the internet that's now
possible
one of the most expensive mistakes ever
made so trends now makes millions of
dollars in subscription revenue it's a
really good business
had we made
relatively minor changes like not that
different like it wouldn't have cost us
more money we maybe would have had a few
more people
and we right now we charge 300 a year
there's a world where wouldn't have had
to been that much different and it
definitely would have been a similar
amount of work we could have charged 30
000 a year right
and
i didn't understand that for a long time
now i completely do where it's like well
actually
we were talking about that with hustle
con when you were doing hustle con the
hustle con ticket was what like 200 300
or something like that yeah on average
and you had told me because i was like
dude why are you doing this like events
business dude events businesses can be
big look at this one look at that one
and i went and looked at him because you
were right they did actually like make
tens of millions of dollars but i was
like dude the ticket price of this is
three grand minimum and it looks like
they have a 15 000 ticket package for
like some people
yours is like 10 times cheaper than that
and you were like yeah we should we
could
but you didn't feel comfortable going
that route or whatever i don't know what
your reason was because you know
yeah i knew i was being there's a few
things one i was a [__] so i was just i
was being fearful and number two when i
started my company i was like 24 what i
don't and i never had a job before what
i don't understand is how these young
guys uh like people who are 21 22 23
like when the folks who started box.com
which is an enterprise cloud company
they were like
20 or 19 like in college still what i
don't understand is when you're a 1920
or in my case i was 24 when i thought
about the company i was like well like i
don't have any money i would never buy
something that was two thousand dollars
now that i'm older and i have more
experience i realize well two thousand
dollars is not a lot of money and so
what i don't understand is how these
young guys who are in their early
twenties who don't have a lot of
experience how they even fathom that
someone's willing to spend all this
money on their product they're either
just courageous or they have more faith
i don't know what it is but i but kudos
to them because when i was 24 and
starting my thing even though i could
have charged way more money and i tell
everyone to do it now i did not have the
courage or the knowledge to do it back
then right and you see now because
you're inside hubspot you see how much
companies spend on just stuff like what
amount of money it's like it's like
going to a really wealthy person's house
and then you see them tip you know you
they tip some guy 100 bucks or they you
know they buy this this fancy espresso
machine for eight thousand dollars it's
like
oh these are normal expenses for them so
then when you're on the outside you're
like i should be charging a lot more but
when you've never been inside one of
these big companies it feels like a
three thousand dollar ask dude i better
be giving them like my left arm and it's
like actually they feel more comfortable
with larger price tags and that's like
that in fact a 300 product is a little
bit off-putting to them and sort of
strange to them
yeah it's it's like disrespectful it's
like dude this this thing isn't good
charge more so like
knowing what i know now and i think uh
mark andreessen
like i forget like this it was a very
like headliney quote but it was
something like if marc andreessen had
one advice for his his startups it would
be simple charge more he goes two words
charge more
and uh
because most startups do what i did you
charge way little uh way less than you
should because you
i don't know you're trying to be cute i
don't know what it is it's just it's
cuter to be cheaper uh but it's like
insecurity right because at the
beginning you're like oh i just want
some customers it's not that big of a
deal then you kind of then that becomes
the anchor point that you mentally
anchor to and the market anchors you to
and then you're afraid if you raise
prices and everybody's gonna run out the
door
um you know what happens if i raise
these prices i'm gonna get complaints
people are gonna quit you know blah blah
and so it's it's really like a form of
insecurity and it's like a corporate
insecurity and uh and so if you're out
there uh i tweeted this the other day i
was like if you're working at a company
go ask for a raise today
but do you think anyone did that there's
a
cycle i just got a promotion go ask for
a raise today
but i'm i'm i don't know i haven't
really proven myself go ask for a raise
today everybody should go ask for a
raise inside of a big company why
because there's almost always wiggle
room like when i was hiring they would
they had what they called a compensation
band what does that mean it means for
the same role we can pay this much on
the low end or this much on the high end
and guess what you start people low or
in the middle of the scale and then you
flex up when you need to when do you
need to when they ask for more money and
so like so there's already in your exact
role without getting a promotion there
is more money that can be had the second
thing is what's the worst that happens
they say no and when they say no you
might learn something they might say no
because like they might give you
essentially a soft hell no well it's a
soft hell no hell no is sort of like
they say no and they they're like look
if you want more you can go elsewhere
and get it that's kind of you're not so
valued here like go for it or there's a
no that's like look
we love you we value you
i would love to give you more i just
can't right now because of xyz or can
you demonstrate can you hit these goals
because that will help us
build this case and hey you're one step
closer to making more money than you
were before you asked and so or they say
yes and boom you get more money like
there's no there's no loss
i was uh except if you work for me don't
come ask me for more money that doesn't
count because i gave this advice so
don't ask me but you know other people
this is for other people i was notorious
at the hustle because when people would
ask me for a raise i'd always say yes
it was i was horrible at confrontation i
just said yes to everything i'm like oh
my god i don't feel like dealing with
this that is not true dude you told me a
hilarious story we can bleep this out if
you want to tell it i don't know if you
remember me you and our friend sully we
were at uh de la rosa or we were at some
some restaurant
and you told the story
of okay bleep this do you remember this
no
i don't remember fully but you were just
like
um
no and you can leave if you think that
and it was just like it wasn't just nose
like you don't understand
like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so the story
was like
well yeah so i remember this so i should
rephrase this when people do good i'm i
say yes to everything when people do bad
they're like well i want to raise i'm
all right so you're like you are a
machine to me that sounds horrible but
it's like
look like our business is a machine and
like humans are like part of the input
humans effort are part of the input
right and you're asking me for a raise
right now i think that the money that
you were paid like breaks even it's like
we put money into this into this machine
we put input out and we get the same
amount out if i'm gonna give you more
amount of money i'm putting more input
how much bigger is the output gonna be
because right now i don't think it's i
don't think that it's worth it and so
i don't think it's worth it it's and and
so if you don't think that that's fair
then you should go to some other machine
and figure out where that input can have
a bigger output because right now it
ain't working right
yeah exactly
so i loved that i loved that because
it was honest uh
b
it was a little bit brutal and uh you
know it wasn't like i would say you have
many many super strengths like a plus
skills like i would pick you over
anybody uh
softly wording
things
is not not one of them
so i found it to be super funny but but
really again even if you find that
information out and it hurts in the
moment
that this person says look it's not like
it's not on the table with the way
things are currently at
if you find that out
you know that's a good that's a good
piece of information it hurts in the
moment but it's a good piece of
information to know because you might
say [__] i need to create more value
here what would it mean and you could
have a conversation you could say well
what would i be needing to do
for you to feel great about paying me
double what i'm making today that's a
question you can ask they might not know
the answer on top of that but they'll
come up with it they'll help work with
you on it and then you'll realize oh
that's where the value is created in my
business and so maybe in this machine
that's where the machine needs the oil i
should go oil that part of it and create
all this new output and then of course
they'll give me some more because i've
created all i've created
disproportionately more value out of it
and so it's a good conversation to go
have
if you haven't had it you know with with
the people you work with
all right good well
i'll let people say we're going to do
that um all right good pod yeah let's
get out of here
[Music]
looking back